Let's go back and talk about pixels.
By the way everybody know
what pixels stands for?
Pixels stands for picture element.
If you talked to a television
engineer thirty years ago,
forty years ago, he talked about pels.
Computer people call them pixels.
Television people call them pels.
Little bit of information.
So we know that we have pixels
at every sort of location,
x y in image it has some we'll
just use the word color for now.
So let's zoom in on a little,
area, here and we take a look at
some particular pixel, and we can say,
that pixel's at X location,
here it says 243, Y location of 84,
and what's the value in that pixel?
Well the value actually
was three of them, right?
And here they are.
A red, a 150, a 173, and
81 written as R G and B values.
Those are the values, the intensities
of each of the three channels.
Red, green and blue.
All right?
So, the color, here, are vectors.
Remember, we talked about
them as being a vector image?
Right?
So, at every location,
we get a different vector.
By the way, you see, over here, on this
white pixel, it says 254, 255, 251.
This is obviously an eight bit
image that goes from zero to 255.
If this was a floating point number
that we let go from zero to one or
floating point image, then that would
be you know 0.98, 0.999 or 1.0 and
0.97 or something like.
All right.
So those three values together,
give you the perceived color.
When you're displaying an image,
what you're really doing
is you're plotting a different
locations on the screen.
A vector by essentially turning on a red
light or green light and a blue light.
You're essentially doing a plot of
those colors, but when you look at it,
it looks like a, picture, alright?
What would happen if instead
of plotting them in x y,
you plotted them in RGB space?
Okay?
So you're going to make them be the same
color as before, but you're going to put
them down in a, in a three dimensional
space not according to x, y, but
according to what their RGB value is.
Well, so here I have that
same little picture, and
I pull out the first, pixel.
And you can see here that red is 152,
green 50, blue 40.
So that's what down here and
this is in this three dimensional space.
All right?
Here's another point closer to white, so
it's all the way up, in the corner, and
finally, here's a,
third point, all right?
So these are plotting these
pixels in the RGB Space.
So we go from Image Space
to Color Space.
So, let's take those fruit pixels,
and plot them all in RGB Space.
What would that look like?
Well, it would look like this, and
this is sort of, kind of an elegant,
three dimensional, plot of that.
And what you can notice right away
is that the pixels are sort of
grouped, right?
These kind of reddish pixels presumably
have something to do with the apples.
You know, what are these whitish pixels,
we'll they're going to
be the background.
And here are these yellowish pixels,
probably have to do with the oranges.
And you start to think about, you know,
we might be able to use your location in
color space, to try to segment out
the different parts of the image.